good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can crush
your self-doubt rule number two is my
personal favorite and I'm curious if you
grow which one you guys like the best we
all doubt ourselves I doubt myself every
day
I still do is it's a work in progress
and I think that's the thing about it
it's not as if you say I'm happy that I
got it I got the keys to happiness but I
think there's a certain thing that you
can do which I try to point out what I
do in the book that are triggers so when
you realize that maybe I am doubting
myself that you can change your thought
print train of thought to get back on
the positive side and and I think that's
what it's all about it's not it's no
secret formula in a lot of ways but it's
about recognizing when you're doing
those things to yourself and how to
correct them and get back in line
first enemy we all have is doubt you
know we doubt whether or not we're
capable we doubt whether or not we're
worthy we doubt whether or not we'll
succeed we doubt whether or not we even
deserve it and it's so unfortunate
because I think doubt is one of the
greatest enemies of our lives and it's
so easy to overcome but most people
won't practice the discipline of
overcoming it which is weird right there
say oh I'm so doubtful and they stop and
it's like if you have any negative
recurring emotion in your life doesn't
maturity require you to face it and say
hey how do I fix this
you know if you're always doubtful you
can't just wander around saying oh I'm
so doubtful like some kind of victim
that that's not fair to the humanity
you've been given that that real power
of free will that says hey you can
direct your consciousness that's why you
have this big prefrontal cortex other
animals can't we can so handle it if
you've been plagued with doubt your
whole life then face it stop running
from it I know that sounds hard to say
to people but I was I have the same
story I was so doubtful that people
would won't care about what I say I was
so doubtful that people would want to
read my books or listen to me at all I
was so doubtful that I could chase my
own dreams and I realized for what
reason am i doubtful because of past
failures in the space no I'm trying
something new because people told me I
might not be able to do it so what makes
them an expert on my capabilities and my
potentialities I thought well why am I
so doubtful we're doubtful because the
the germ of fear spread in our body
because somebody planted it there one
time or we cultivated with our own
thoughts and at some point maturity and
consciousness says if doubt has been
plaguing you let's have a look at it and
let's realize well how do you banish it
well every single thing that we know
from spirituality from philosophy from
the great writers in the great text of
human culture has all revealed one thing
where there is doubt grant me faith
that we have to have faith and faith
does not mean the absent of doubt matter
of fact the very definition of faith
realize a doubt is still there right you
can't have faith unless there's some
part of you says well I'm gonna go
anyway
despite the doubt so I'm not saying we
have to get rid of doubt forever and
handle it I'm saying doubt should never
prevent you from advancing when you feel
like advancing that in your own mind you
must say okay I must trust in my
abilities I must trust that I will
figure it out I must trust it I can
build it I must trust that I can get
some help and progress even though the
doubt might be there look the hero is a
hero because the hero does it anyway
right even though the hero is terrified
and risking it all goes anyway and we're
all heroes in some way we can all be
courageous but I also think you know
what society over blows courage Society
says you know courage has to be some big
magnificent act but it's not I mean
courage in this world anymore is just
having them the belief in yourself and
having the jit the ability to genuinely
express who you are if you're doubting
yourself the only way through is to give
yourself more faith and take more action
and with more faith and more action
comes more competence with more
competence comes more confidence in
psychology they call it the confidence
confidence loop right the more you learn
and try the more you master and develop
so go out there even with that yes let
the doubt be there but do it anyway
overcoming the negative conversation
that inner dialog is going on all the
time all the time even when you don't
want it to be there you can't stop
yourself right now from thinking you
can't do it it's going on and so
learning how to empower yourself part of
doing that is standing up to yourself
you've got to stand up inside yourself
sometimes and say shut up
you've got to do this I was going to
give a presentation and this voice
inside of me saying you can't do this
you don't have everything it takes us
shut up
yeah behind on my bills are you telling
me what I can't do I have got to do it
you get scared sometimes your mind will
go blink on you some people will you
will allow to unnerve you and you wonder
what's wrong with me I'm not crazy
that's why you've got to learn to make a
conscious deliberate determined effort
to stand up inside yourself working on
yourself watching that inner dialogue it
will determine the quality of your life
how do you handle something get rid of
it you don't get rid of self-doubt
through the same means by which you
learned it and that is in the head
self-doubt is purely a head created
phenomenon you were taught it and you do
it to yourself
your heart and your balls have a
brilliance to them that allow them to do
some magnificent [ __ ] without this guy
getting in the way and that's what it
means when you get in your own way
that's what self-doubt is the fastest
band-aid ripped off remedy to fixing
this terrible situation is to do the
thing you're afraid to do doing it's not
about feeling confident about going into
the situation it's not about knowing
that it's going to work out it's not
about having the most detailed plan for
how this thing will happen it's about
doing it courage you get courage is what
you will experience and what you will
grow when the doubt is there but you do
it anyway so your problem isn't doubt
your problem is courage doubt is going
to be there but doubt gets out of the
way when you express courage right doubt
is like it's burned off by courage Ralph
Waldo Emerson says do the thing and you
will have the power we're waiting
waiting waiting waiting for the power
waiting not to self doubt any longer
right whatever it is that you're
deciding that you want to do with
yourself that you're doubting your
Dion just do it [ __ ] it up completely
that's another thing that you've got to
get through your mind is that success is
not doing the right thing and it
definitely isn't doing the right thing
the first time success is having the
courage to move in the direction of your
dreams move in a direction that your
heart is taking you that is what success
is as you are progressively realizing
that thing people think success is I've
got a plan and I go and work out that
plan it never ever ever ever ever works
that way success is the progressive
realisation of a worthy goal but
progressive realization means that
you're doing things that you don't know
how to do you're stepping out in faith
you're being courageous your self-doubt
will step out of the way when you build
the balls to do the thing and the power
will be added to you
Force One is embodiment so before I get
into it I got to kind of tell you how it
works the subconscious and the conscious
mind speak different languages I alluded
to this earlier the conscious mind is
verbal right we talked to our friends
our family but you can even talk to
ourselves in a way that is it's English
in our head but the way that we feel
things right that you can talk to
yourself all day but it's very very
difficult to talk yourself into feeling
a certain way what you need to do is
have an experience even if that
experience is imagined so the
subconscious mind speaks and experiences
while the conscious mind kind of speaks
more in language that we use every
single day so in getting to how do we
experience something we want to embody
the release of that self-doubt so one of
the most helpful ways that I've ever
encountered I do all the time is when I
have a negative feeling particularly
self-doubt I will free right
what that means is I'll pull up a Word
document you can go to 750 pages calm
check it out there's another French one
that is easy three pages dot fr and it
gives you a thing 750 words is about
three pages and it's enough time to just
type right and count your words for you
type everything that's bothering you I
feel this way because this said that and
now I'm going back and forth my
dump it all actually feel it being
poured onto the page if you want to free
write it some people enjoy this better
with hand that can give you that feeling
of just catharsis of getting it out and
this is important this is not just a
metaphor because once you've gotten it
out of that page and that website you
shut down the browser close the computer
turn it off and there is this feeling of
closure if you have a Word document you
drag it to the trash you empty the trash
and it's gone if there's a piece of
paper you light it on fire
and it's so weird because why would this
help you but the subconscious mind
speaks and experience and what that
experience was I dumped all my feelings
here and then I lit it on fire and it's
gone it is incredible how effective that
is if you want to put it on steroids
again you can kind of trick your
subconscious mind if there's someone
that's bothering you
what you can do is after you've done
everything you've like gotten it all out
there you go back and you write a letter
to yourself from that person apologizing
for whatever they did it or explaining
why they did what they did
clearly it's your own voice clearly this
isn't coming from them but guess what
your subconscious does not care and that
feeling of closure is palpable so now
you know that you should feel good and
you actually feel good and again you
light that on fire and it's gone it
feels so much better that is embodiment
there's tons of different ways but that
is the simplest and most effective that
I found to clear out self down so if
there's something you got right now
start here if it's recurring your life
write it out delete it burn it get rid
of it but make sure first you have that
feeling of pouring it outside of
yourself so it doesn't feel stuck I was
playing a game against the 49ers a
Monday night game and I had to sex that
game and I had ten sacks on the year
which is great by football terms and I
was on my way he's going to another Pro
Bowl which means I won the best in the
NFL but I felt horrible I felt like I
was one of the worst players didn't feel
good about myself and and I went to some
money at Arizona who you know just
reinforced that you have to speak kindly
to yourself you have to talk nicely to
yourself treat yourself and say to
yourself well you would say to somebody
else to encourage them and
that's what I started to do and the next
week had a big game to get the Cardinals
and it was in my opinion in 15 years in
the NFL the best and greatest football
game I've ever played and I think it was
it was because I truly told myself you
can do this you know how to play this
game you belong in this game and I've
had to use that to do live how did you
do use it to do Fox because I wasn't so
sure I could be a sports commentator
which a lot of people think is natural
for an athlete to be able to do but it's
not and then they come to morning
television I've had to tell myself to
have to do GMA I've had to tell myself
that because I'm as scared and as
fearful as anybody else to tackle
something new but I've learned that
sometimes I got to get over the fear of
not doing it because I'm scared instead
of not doing it because I can't do it
and I found that I was more just worried
about being scared and what what the
repercussions were actually more than
really feeling like I couldn't do
something and now by taking these
chances I feel like I can do anything I
think once you get to the point of where
you don't really care about anyone elses
opinion and you really truly trust in
yourself and you're willing to put
yourself in an uncomfortable position
you'll find that you'll get comfortable
real quick and you can do things that
you never in a million years thought
that you'd be able to accomplish and I'm
a true believer that it's all what you
think of it it's all what you think of
yourself it's all what you apply to it
it's all about the work that you put
into it and if you put all those things
and you apply and you really are
interested in something then you can do
it I have no doubt in anybody every
thing is possible so I have two quick
thoughts on this as well that I wanted
to add in for me the first step in
destroying self-doubt is understanding
what you stay in for it's figuring out
your one word right it's why I wrote a
book on it when you can understand what
it is that you stand for when you
understand what you believe in then it's
so much harder for someone to squash you
down where a lot of people are just
living a reactionary life where when you
understand that thing that really means
the world to you so for me it's about
believed you can't crush me anymore
because I know my path I have certainty
when you have certainty you
don't have the self-doubt you don't
worry when other people criticize you
because you know the path that you're on
and sorry highly encourage all of you to
figure out what it is that you staying
for to create that certainty within
yourself so that other people's opinions
don't impact you so that your own
negative talk doesn't impact you it goes
away because you know the path that
you're on the second part that I'd add
is also expect to suck at the start a
lot of times when you're starting
something you know what looks good and
you want to be that good but you can't
be that good yet at the start because
you're first starting out you might be
starting on YouTube when you look at
somebody's videos you might be looking
at my video say I want to be like Evan
okay that's a good goal in your first
video it's gonna suck
you know if I want to be like Les Brown
great the first time I get on stage I'm
gonna suck just expect a suck no matter
how much preparation hard work and
antigen after you put into it you're
gonna suck the first time you do
anything and that's okay and then next
thing you do it again you get better
like anything else any skill that you've
learned from the English language or
whatever language you speak to whatever
music instrument you might play to
whatever sport you've picked up the
first time you try that you sucked
that's what always happens and then with
persistence and follow-through you get
better we're because a lot of people
know what's good and then they try it
and they realize that they're not as
good as I thought they might be then
that self-doubt keeps saying like oh
maybe I can't do it maybe I can't like
it looks so easy to do a youtube video
and then I did my own and it was so bad
maybe I won't be able to go out and do
that expect to suck at the start it
really releases a lot of the
self-criticism a lot of the self-doubt
because you expect it going in and all
you're doing is daily trying to get
better and better and better than what
you were yesterday so those are my quick
thoughts I love to know what do you guys
think what did you learn from this video
that you can apply in your life for your
business how do you overcome and crush
self-doubt leaving comments below I'm
going to join in the discussion I also
made this video because Toulouse Amman
asked me to so this is topic you'd like
me to cover in the next edition of
believe life leave it down the comments
below and I'll see what I can do
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day I believe in you I hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love
season